i know that four seasons backdrop are
you guys doing
all right you're right thank you how are
you i'm doing good uh both of you guys
were great in the movie i just want to
start with that um so i am curious do
you guys think that if the eternals have
been allowed to fight thanos
on their own do you think they could
have beaten him
i think they would have given it a good
go
yeah
although i kind of think icarus is kind
of like he'd be like yeah
why am i doing this i could be doing
something else you know i think
he's kind of less motivated in that
angle of things he's like yeah okay
whatever
this this uh i am curious when you guys
got involved and you're talking to
marvel and chloe about your powers and
you know that kind of stuff did they
explain to you each of your powers and
like the limitations
and like what kind of damage you could
get into when you're fighting or is it
sort of like
what did they say
it was like a developing story it'd be
on set and you'd be like wait okay so
can i do like a small burst of like
energy eyes or is each one can i like
regulate that could i like heat up a
pack of popcorn or as like every time
i'm gonna like blow a hole in a building
like what's the variations here what
control do i have so it was quite fun
doing that and then we wanted to try and
get
you know those character cards with like
you know strength ten
powers seven for each one to be like we
who can beat each other's ass i don't
know which can do what yeah there were
debates amongst you guys like who would
win the fight like between like icarus
and then that was an ongoing thing i
don't think we've ever resolved
uh so yeah that would have been helpful
to kind of have those cards um no as
richard said it was a developing thing
that we we kind of discovered and we're
like can i
can i leap up here can i kind of do that
because they're not i mean cersei her
powers are to be able to to manipulate
mata and to change something something
else and obviously her powers actually
kind of develop over the course of the
movie as well so yeah it was something
that we we discovered
yeah because i think for me i mean i'm
always wondering like who could actually
like take down the other person can you
get hit you know what i mean like
how much damage can you essentially take
before it's a fatal blow if you know
what i mean
i think it's quite hard to kill an
eternal um
because none of us had died
well with that knife from sprite you
went down
hey well i mean i went down for a bit
but then it didn't you know
go back all right i'll give you that
um but no but obviously ajax can heal so
we're always he'll heal by ajax
but i feel like it's only the deviants
that could really kill us
right
before i run out of time i want to ask
another question which is um you guys
were actually the first
uh love scene in an mcu movie and um
what did that actually uh did you know
that going in that this was gonna be
you'd be able to do something like that
what did it actually mean to you
no we had no idea really um
but it you know those those scenes can
sometimes be
a little bit tricky but i felt very
lucky that i was with my friend uh with
richard yeah yeah it makes it a lot
easier when you're with
someone you trust and care about and you
can kind of look after each other seems
always really uncomfortable and uh
and not very fun and to try and make you
look relaxed and intimate when you've
got you know 300 people watching you
so it's really not a friend with you
that you know we trust um we'll just try
and make it as easy as possible
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say i hope it's a huge hit thank you so
much for giving me your time
you